bonjour et bienvenue dans l'émission les
petits bricoleurs aujourd'hui je vais
vous montrer comment fabriquer un jeu de
dames
pour cela nous avons besoin d'un carton
de 35 sur 35 cm
du papier de journal
une règle un crayon à papier une paire
de ciseaux
un pinson de la colle et des bouchons de
couleur différente c'est possible
on commence par tracer le quadrillage du
d'année
à l'aide de la règle et du crayon on
trace une ligne toutes les trois des
cinq centimètres dans le sens de la
longueur et dans le sens de la largeur
on prête moi des mules 5 cm
donc du moment qu'on a fait des repères
qui maintenant vont tirer les lignes on
va faire des trucs des lignes
dans le sens horizontal juive
dans le sens vertical
tu dois retrouver au final
sans petit carré de trois légumes 5 sur
trois nuls cinq centimètres
dans cette aventure va prendre le
journal on va couper les petits carrés
pour coller sur le jeu de dames
on va plier
et l'accordéon c'est possible
pour moi on pourra enlever le surplus
est là on va reprendre les mêmes
dimensions que le damier dont 3 5 cm
à
on
va couper
donc là c'est trop les 3800
donc on aura on devrait avoir 60 petits
carrés de 3,5 cm sur 3 légaux 5 cm
est donc maintenant on va coller
donc pour coller au bas
sauter une 15
donc c'est tout les deux cases je trouve
affolé
quand
je
maintenant on a déjà positionné le
damier il nous reste plus qu'à mettre
les bouchons
e
vous
alors le jeu de dames ayant terminé il
ne reste plus qu'à vous amuser et moi je
vous dis au revoir et la prochaine
émission